welcome everyone to the data science
hangout and a lot of you have been here
before but if this is your first time
it is an open space for current and
aspiring data science leaders
really to just connect and chat about
some of the more human-centric questions
around data science leadership
so we really want to create a space
where everybody can participate and hear
from everyone
from the community
so there's three ways that you could ask
questions you could jump in live
put questions in the chat
and we also have a slido link that rob
will share shortly
but you could ask anonymous questions
there too
and just a quick note for everyone that
it is recorded so be shared up to
youtube as well for anybody who's missed
it
but i am so excited to
introduce my co-hosts for today's
hangout
marav who is co-founder and ceo of data
society
and marav i'd love to have you also just
introduce yourself and share a little
bit about the work you do and and data
society
thanks rachel thank you so much for
having me um i love doing these types of
events so it's so great to see y'all uh
if you have a camera you feel like
turning it on i love to see people uh if
not that's fine too i understand people
might be running around with kids in the
background and or eating lunch so that's
absolutely acceptable
uh as rachel said my name is maravir
lifker ceo and co-founder of data
society
just to give you a bit of a background
as to who i am i'm a teacher first and
foremost i actually started my career in
the classroom way back in the day in new
york city public schools
and spent several years
in the education space before starting
data society and the reason why we
started it is because we saw
that there were a lot of professionals
in the space who needed to understand
how to use data but didn't have
forty thousand dollars to get a master's
degree
didn't have hundreds of hours to spend
looking through youtube videos and we
saw an opportunity to build
practical customized training programs
to deliver specifically to federal
agencies as well as fortune 500
companies to really help
people get up to speed quickly because
what we believe and i'm sure what a lot
of you do as well is that when you layer
a data skill set on top of the industry
knowledge that many people already have
you are
really transforming the way that people
work and the way that industries run and
our goal is to help industries uh and
and companies become more data driven
because we think that's what's going to
lead to the greatest innovative leaps um
and it gives us the most power to be
able to solve a lot of the challenges
that we're seeing in today's space so
we're really passionate about helping
people understand how to use data
we also have our consulting side frankly
it just came out of
teaching when you teach what you do a
lot of people ask you to do what you
teach
so we build custom software predictive
algorithms help with digital
transformation and and we do a lot on
that side of it as well
um you know we're based in washington dc
but we have
offices in richmond and we have folks
all over the country especially as we've
gone remote during the pandemic
so that's a little bit about me
and who i am and what i do
thank you rob and while we're waiting
for some questions to come in from the
audience
i'm just curious what does that process
look like when you start with a new
client and are starting off that whole
training process
yeah that's a good question
we're very much focused on solutions and
outcomes so for us every single client
that we have um has a bit of a
consultative approach at first we talk
about what are learning objectives what
are people's current skill sets we also
deliver assessments that can help people
actually understand what skill sets are
so we go through that and then we
develop customized pathways
based on those objectives and the
starting points and we have an in-house
team of data scientists as well as
instructional designers that work
together to make sure that all the
content that we deliver is best of breed
we work with a lot of instructors who
have industry experience we have
in-house instructors as well
and our main goal is really to create a
good
experience where people can walk away
and actually immediately start to use
the skills that they have so a lot of
our programs also have capstone projects
which are a really great way to
demonstrate return on investment and
also application of data skills directly
to a challenge that they're facing um
there's actually one other piece that i
didn't mention which is as we
expanded our technical uh training what
we saw is that there's a bigger gap that
we're trying to bridge right now which
is um the communication gap between data
and non-data professionals we've seen
that's a really big pain point in a lot
of organizations so we actually have our
whole non-technical series that works
with executives managers and general
staff so that people can all speak the
same language because we want to
facilitate that level of collaboration
and communication across an organization
that's awesome
i'm thinking that from the audience here
there's also a lot of people who are
maybe doing this training internally at
their organizations or are like the one
kind of spearheading that and getting
people interested so do you have any
kind of tips or best practices for doing
that
yes first of all congratulations and
that's a really hard job to have um so
i'm always happy to help if you ever
want to chat with me specifically about
that
one of the biggest ways that we've seen
um
that can facilitate interest in this
type of training is to demonstrate the
value that it has so if you have data
science teams who are using data
analytics or there's a particular
project within your industry or your
organization that was successful
shout it from the rooftops get some
lunch and learns get that newsletter out
make sure that people are aware of the
benefits that they can have if they
start to implement these skills and then
the other piece of it is make sure that
you have data champions in high places
um what we've seen especially to start
with is if you don't have a mandate from
the top to become more data driven i
mean most people just won't take the
time out of their day to learn these
skills because they don't feel like it's
mandated so it has to come from the top
you have to have folks saying
we need to make sure that we're using
these metrics that you understand what
they mean we need to be asking questions
about where this data is coming from we
need to make sure that our data is kept
securely
and having that type of conversation
come from the top helps give cover to
people in a way who want to take the
time out of their day but maybe weren't
able to before because maybe their
direct supervisor
didn't see the value in it so um get a
data champion that's high up there and
then make sure any successful data
projects that you have
are well publicized
are two tips that i would give
thank you and
feel free anyone to raise your hand too
if you want to or i can take people
unmuting as
raising their hand as well
but just to follow up on that so finding
that data champion higher up in the
company
how like how should you actually go
about doing that if you're part of a
large organization
yeah it's not always easy that's what
i'll say um
politics and in large organizations can
vary sometimes they're less difficult
than others i would say start with the
allies you know you have if there's one
person even if they're your colleague as
opposed to
somebody higher up just get together
start talking about maybe building
something like this an event like this
internally right once a month you just
meet people who are interested in using
data start to get a quorum so that when
you go to a supervisor or an executive
you can demonstrate the level of
interest that your organization has
the other piece of it is um
bring in other examples of companies
that might be more data driven than
yours
because we all want to make sure we
won't become obsolete uh and what i've
seen is that organizations now if they
are not um
going towards this whole uh holistic
data literacy and building a data
culture if
if organizations aren't moving towards
that
it's going to be very difficult for them
to keep up with the market in the next
five to 10 years and when you say things
like that to an executive audience they
tend to listen so if you see that your
competitors or other um
you know players in your industry are
doing this that's another good motivator
especially for those at the executive
level
thank you
i see a follow-up anonymous question
that came in on slido um when you
mentioned well publicized how do you
what do you mean by making sure your
work's well publicized
so um if there is a project that went
well
i would look at what avenues you have
available to you to just disseminate
that information i personally love lunch
and learns because just like this one
because it highlights a person who's
doing a great job and also encourages
knowledge sharing across an organization
if you have enough people who are
participating it tends to disseminate uh
so i would do that if there are
newsletters
i know
we work with a very large client he said
they get 20 newsletters a week sometimes
it's not really the best avenue but for
a lot of folks you also might have slack
you might have microsoft teams um
you know if you have
any media outlets i know that
organizations love to show how data
driven they are so if you are in touch
with your marketing team or your pr team
i mean throw that at them you know that
may be something they would want to
do a little press release about or
potentially reach out to one of their
contacts so there are a few different
ways to go about it um to try to garner
that level of attention
that's a great point
um frank i see you asked a question in
the chat if you want to ask that live
hi frank
hey folks good to see everyone again
um this is a really fascinating way to
start the hour um you got me wondering
is there any tips that you have to
try to find the balance between hey
let's do this we
we got in a huddle we have this idea we
have this project let's see it through
and hopefully once we get it we can put
it in the newsletter or we can
put it out there on social media and
show people that we're data driven
but man we can't wait right you don't
wait three six twelve months to for that
cycle to happen
is there a way like that you work faster
um
i don't know to experiment to say like
oh yeah this is the right direction or
no like like let's pivot and be okay
with pivoting and try something else
that's a great question um
the short answer is it depends on the
project you want to focus on so and it
also depends on the data that you have
so especially if you're starting from a
point where you just want to get
something off the ground start with the
data that you have because data
collection uh i think as many of us know
can take three six nine months depending
on the type of data that you have so if
you have data that you think can answer
maybe one or two questions that you have
that would be relevant to some of the
challenges that your team is facing your
department
um look for that low-hanging fruit
because once you have the data
the cycle to actually go through
cleaning can take a while
hopefully your data is in good shape but
once you have that it's pretty
straightforward to run through any data
visualizations if you want to build a
dashboard or alternatively if you're
running it through some machine learning
algorithms that whole prototyping
process is pretty um
quick and if you have i would also start
with a small amount of data just to see
if you're on the right track so take a
subset of your data um you know train
your model on that then test it and then
see if it works out and you know if not
that's okay that's all part of the
process it's hard to guarantee a good
outcome when we're doing this type of
work
lovely yeah you got me thinking
thank you yeah i always i'm a big
advocate it's so hard
for especially large organizations like
this is not a one-month project this is
a multi-year project so i always
recommend especially for just getting
started look for the low-hanging fruit
like where are the people in your
company that you know would be big
advocates for this where's the data that
you know if
even put into a visual interactive
dashboard would garner that type of
attention that's where you want to start
with i love data visualization because
it's uh usually presented in a way that
most people understand and it's less
intimidating
to executives who might not
know how to use data everybody loves to
look at a pretty picture and point to
trends right that's a a nice and easy
way to get people on board
thank you rob
there is an anonymous question earlier
that was how do you measure the success
of a data science project or client
engagement
but also how do you help companies
define this
so how do we do it uh as a company
i think that's the question but probably
also how they could do that as well yeah
yeah
the key to defining success is defining
the metrics that you want to look at and
that's true of a data science project
it's true of any of the programs that we
run because
at the end of the day you could say is a
policy that we've developed successful
but if you don't know what metrics to
measure it's very hard to answer that
question so the first thing that we want
to do that we do and that i would
recommend for anyone when starting out
with a data science project is
what's the key question you're trying to
answer and what are the metrics that
you're going to use to answer that
question so for example if you want to
take a look at the effectiveness of a
marketing campaign for example the
question could be um
maybe how how many people want to buy a
certain product or click on a particular
ad and then what are the metrics that
you're using well you're probably using
people who click on it but maybe you
also want to take at the click-through
rate maybe you'll see that out of a
thousand people that saw it only five
people clicked on the ad is that a
successful rate for you you would have
to compare that against other baseline
rates that you've done if you've run
another campaign that maybe had a
hundred clicks then maybe that's not a
successful campaign but if this campaign
is garnering clicks and another one
didn't then i would consider that a
success as well so you want to take the
baseline measures you want to make sure
you're defining your metrics correctly
and you want to also make sure you're
answering it asking the right question
a lot of times asking the right question
and then getting the right data there's
a bit of a back and forth there because
if you don't ask the right question at
first you might be collecting data and
metrics that are not relevant so what
you want to do is um
just make sure that the metrics are well
defined before starting any of those
projects and that will help
define success
through that
thank you
hugh i know you asked a question in the
chat earlier and i can see that libby
gave a plus one to that too so i'd love
to
to go over to that question next if you
want to ask live
sure
um hey my name's uh hugh i'm an analyst
with the va
i did want to start with i love what you
just said about picking important
metrics my background is like process
improvement systems redesign and that's
a challenge
how do you uh figure out what customers
value uh and then measure it um so i
really like that um
i like your your comment about lunch and
learns or forums like this uh i host a
monthly thing uh internally for vha
where we do something eerily similar um
and one of the challenges that i face is
uh especially since covett and it's all
virtual um sometimes it feels like
you're talking to this uh nameless
faceless room of people
do you have any advice on uh kind of
getting people to
participate or chime in so that it's not
this
more of a monologue than you know me
talking to a you know talking instead of
listening
absolutely that's a great question and
i'm so glad to hear that you're that
you're doing that event um i love to
hear those types of examples one way
that we found to be really effective is
to break out into small groups
so ask a discussing question and then
break people out into four to five
people per group
uh and give the folks you know five to
seven minutes to discuss the question
internally and then have them come back
and designate one person to actually um
tell you what they talked about
the reason why i recommend that is
because in a large group like this
people are generally shy you know they
know they don't really have to
participate and maybe they just want to
listen but when you get folks into a
smaller group environment all of a
sudden there's more pressure to appear
on camera to participate
so um we've seen a lot of people open up
this way this is how we run a lot of our
trainings actually now that we're doing
live streaming and we've even gotten
comments from folks saying that it's
more interactive than in person because
they feel like they have to participate
so i would recommend starting off with
like an icebreaker like that even and
then maybe peppering in some of those
questions throughout any presentation
that you do
even if there's less interaction on the
big group
i
am almost positive you're going to see
more interaction in the small groups and
you're going to see more development of
relationships between colleagues which i
found to be one of the most beneficial
aspects of any type of event like this
that's awesome thank you
my pleasure
so the breakouts will start in three two
one yeah see y'all later that's my way
of not talking as much that's uh that's
my excuse
[Laughter]
there's an another anonymous question
that
is could you give some specific examples
of projects that you've helped clients
work through
absolutely
um so i'll give one
on
the consulting side and then i can give
one on the training side as well just so
you see the variety of of work that we
do we recently just finished doing a
digital transformation project with a
financial institution
um
you know small bank
that had a lot of disparate data systems
and didn't really understand where to
start they were also really worried
about compliance and reporting
to
federal agencies like the fdic for
example
so we
ran a project with them where we did a
lot of in-depth conversations with their
leadership team took a look at their i.t
systems
which were
and again this is a nameless company so
not putting them on the spot there were
a lot of excel spreadsheets i'll just
say that
which we like to refer to as dark data
which is data that remains on one
person's laptop and is never ever ever
shared out to anyone else so this is
also just a call out if you have a lot
of um
excel spreadsheets on your laptop you
know all other colleagues do try to find
a shared drive just keep that data
somewhere centralized because um we
found a lot of our insights come from
when we put these types of disparate
data sources together and that's when
you start to see patterns emerge that
you wouldn't have otherwise that's my
little spiel about dark data
back to this we ended up um identifying
a few ways for them to consolidate their
own systems and delivered a final
recommendations report uh in terms of
how to implement that and we're going to
start implementation with them in the
next few months so that's an example of
some of the work that we do on the
consulting side which is just helping
people become
better
uh organized in terms of the data
infrastructure side you know for for our
our training uh side of the house you
know we run uh typically
programs on an annual basis we'll run
several cohorts throughout the year
one of the recent courts that we did was
with the office of management and budget
the omb federal agency we delivered two
cohorts simultaneously across 60
individuals
who
were working with 20 different federal
agencies it was an eight-week program
where we helped them refresh on data
wrangling skills as well as machine
learning fundamentals including
clustering and classification techniques
and then we also supported them through
their capstone projects that they then
presented to
their leadership at capstone
presentations at the end so eight-week
program 64 hours in total um
and each
agency presented their own capstone
project to leadership at the end
and the results that we got out of that
were pretty
great uh in my opinion because what we
were seeing is people collaborating
together who had not necessarily met
before and continuing that conversation
even beyond the program one of my
favorite capstone
presentations was actually done by the
national park service what they did is
they combined weather data along with
geographical data in terms of their
national parks as well as visitor data
to determine the top 10
parking lots where they would put in
solar charging stations
so based on all of those metrics they
identified they taught the top 10
parking lots that they will be putting
in solar charging stations to actually
start to collect revenue and they
estimate that once that is put in place
they'll be able to collect you know 100
000
per year uh per parking lot so just out
of that project we're looking at a
million dollars a year in a new uh
revenue stream that they wouldn't have
had before so those are some of the
examples of projects that we help
students develop
and
can actually create real value right off
the bat so those are some examples that
we have
that's so cool
how did they go about just brainstorming
those ideas
a lot of it came from their mentors so
one of the reasons why i actually really
like the omb program is because
they
uh
had mentors in each agency so the
students who participated met with the
mentors and discussed what project they
wanted to focus on and so they got
guidance from leadership in that regards
awesome edgar i see you had asked a
question earlier around um
well actually it's a longer question so
i'm not going to try and summarize it if
you want to jump in and ask that
yeah it was more so a comment just to
kind of dovetail on what we'll share
that um
you gotta learn where you're improving
from and and most of the time at least
in our early beginnings like four or
five years ago we were improving from
gut feel there wasn't really a baseline
um
and and that's kind of where you want to
start it's what what is your project
improving from
and if it's just basically improving
from somebody's gut feel that something
should be or shouldn't be done
the success of the project in and of
itself is a repeatability of of the
analysis that is being done off of
godfield
yeah absolutely and you know gut feeling
is interesting to me because um
we get a lot of
people who say well i've been in this
industry for 20 to 30 years i know what
i'm doing i don't need data to tell me
what i'm doing
and that's not necessarily something we
ever want to dismiss because listen at
the end of the day computers are good a
lot of things including repetitive um
tasks but we nobody understands no
machine understands concepts and context
better than we do um but i like to point
to this uh example that was a study that
was done
gosh it might be a decade ago now um
where
there was a group of researchers who
um surveyed 80
law professors i can't remember if
they're from harvard or not
and asked them to predict the outcomes
of cases based on
uh the case file and then they also
developed an algorithm to predict
the outcomes of cases as well and in
fact the algorithm outperformed
all of the experience of those law
professors now
that doesn't mean we should throw out
all the law professors and now only
focus on algorithms right obviously
there's a lot of nuance to all of this
but what it does mean is that um we
should always encourage folks to use
data as a starting point as a baseline
to make sure that their gut is headed in
the right direction i don't think that
these types of algorithms will replace
us anytime soon
but what i like to think of them doing
is to augment the skills that we already
have so that we can ensure that we're
making the best decisions possible with
the information that we have
yeah definitely for us a big concern was
you know
succession management too we have people
with like 10 20 30 years doing the same
thing
how do you do knowledge transfer
especially with now newer generations
that don't want to last as long in those
jobs
yeah that's another really great point
that's uh why i love you know code
so something like github or bitbucket um
developing shared um drives to host to
keep all of this data to keep all of
these algorithms and coding templates is
crucial to ensure that you're not
redoing things you have been before or
losing information so
data governance and we haven't really
touched upon this but i data governance
is a really important piece of that just
to set the standard of how data should
be used um and then what the
expectations are so that everyone's
aligning on
on those rules
you know
touching on gut um and that gut feel and
the person with 20 years experience
uh i think kahneman on a podcast once
said something along the lines of like
the most he thinks the most important
mental model of all the stuff that he
he's written about is base rates right
like what is the historical probability
so before we even get to algorithms and
deep data
analytics right how do you get your
users just to start using that
historical probability right start at a
point that is um
perhaps more grounded in truth then
layer on your gut
that's in the right direction
yeah that's exactly right
i see robert you asked a question you
said i can read out loud and i just want
to say if anybody maybe is in a busy
room and doesn't want me to call on them
to ask their question too you can still
put them in the chat maybe put like a
little star at the end and i'll know to
read it
um
but robert asks how do you gain the
trust of a new client after the
engagement starts in other words how do
you make them feel like your team is
delivering value
that's a great question
the key to that is communication and
clarity
what i've found is
building trust takes time of course
and while we say uh that we have
everybody's best interests at heart i
know that there are folks that have
already always had bad experiences with
with people like that right so it's not
enough to say it but we have to show it
so what does that mean um in terms of
our training programs we usually set up
weekly check-ins especially if it's a
longer program
we ensure that we solicit feedback from
students so for some of our longer
programs we also have these very short
check-ins they're typically two
questions the first one is um how
difficult did you find the material so
to help us ensure that we're
meeting their expectations in terms of
skill level and the second one is how
relevant is this material to your work
to make sure that we're always teaching
the the most important topics and we
also have a section for any additional
information so we keep a pulse on how
our students are
feeling during the class so if we see
any thing maybe out of the ordinary we
can address it right away
you know in terms of communication for
uh our consulting projects we operate
very similarly in terms of that level of
communication ensuring we have those
regular touch points ensuring that our
clients understand um the progress that
we're making and then also making sure
that when issues pop up we
bring them up right i think you know
sometimes clients are afraid to come
with me with negative feedback and you
know i get it nobody likes to tell some
somebody anything unpleasant but for me
i i welcome it because that's the only
way that we grow and that we get better
and if i don't know about it then i
won't be able to fix it so
whenever i have conversations like that
the first thing i always say is hey
thank you for bringing this to me right
that's that that should be everybody's
automatic reaction and then the second
piece of it is let's talk about what we
can do what steps we can take to make
sure that you are getting um what you
are expecting from us so a level of that
level of communication and clarity tends
to mitigate any issues that come about
uh and then just making sure if we see
any issues on our side if the data is
not where it's supposed to be
um that we bring that up right away so
that's a long-winded answer of saying
it's just communication more than
anything else that's the number one way
to build a good relationship uh and
that's not even in the professional
field i would just argue that as a
general rule
for sure
and following up on just talking a bit
more about these projects someone had
asked what is the best way to deal with
multiple projects um so what is the
level of priority they usually assign to
a project if this is the case
yeah
good question um
well we're all data people we love our
matrices so i like creating and
evaluating against two different
axes the first one is feasibility and
the second one is impact so if there is
a project that you've identified is
quite feasible and has a high level of
impact so that would be in the upper
right quadrant uh for me if you're
seeing my mirror right here then that's
the one that i would start with first
you and then based on that you can see
okay maybe there's a project somebody
threw in there but it's actually really
difficult to get the data and it's not
going to move the needle for us that
much maybe that would drop to a lower
priority so it's it's really dependent
on the objective that your organization
has as well as the resources that you
have um and then what the timing sense
is because even for a project that's
maybe less feasible right now but has a
high level of impact maybe there are
some
tasks that you can start doing now to
prepare and to improve the feasibility
of that project so if it's data
collection maybe there's something you
can run in the background just to start
collecting data for a project that right
now isn't fusible that might be in three
months when you have more data
definitely i see in the chat
poly as while you were weighing in on
this and you have some feedback on what
you use
feel free to jump in too
yeah
when i started my new role and i did
like a a couple weeks of meeting with
various people and tried to find a way
to rank projects and we sort of landed
on this you know
sort of what you're saying one how hard
is it to what's the impact and then
three
is the business ready for this or not
which is sort of related to impact but
not quite so
we sort of developed an internal you
know weighted number and then uh scaled
it from zero to 100 to figure out what
to do first
using data just to determine those
projects i love it that's great i like
business readiness a lot um i think
that's important we get a lot of clients
who ask us to do neural networks off the
bat uh and i'm like well let's talk
about the data that you have and
then we'll we'll see how it goes from
there um
executives like to
throw around the terms that they are
seeing um without necessarily
understanding the implications behind it
so it's a one of the again this goes
back to building trust one of the
biggest pieces
and biggest responsibilities that we
have is to educate whoever we're
speaking with to make sure they
understand what they're actually asking
for because a lot of time what clients
are asking us to do versus what they
actually need
can be different so that's why we like
to dig in there to make sure that we're
addressing what the actual need is
i see there's a quite a few other
anonymous questions that were asked
earlier and one was how do you go about
from building to serving a predictive
model for your projects
yep um
so in terms of building the model we
have
a
framework that we use we also teach and
it has six steps i'm sure that there are
variations of this all over the place
but we always start with asking the
question so like i mentioned earlier
without the right question it is very
difficult to
build a model that will make an impact
so you want to ask the right question
you want to make sure that you have the
right data
honestly that will take 70 to 80 percent
of any any data project
time because collecting data and
cleaning data can be very labor
intensive
and that also goes back to the piece of
setting up the appropriate data
infrastructure and having the right data
governance in place because if you do
have both of those pieces it
dramatically shortens the amount of time
that your data scientists need to spend
in our python
just wrangling the data and manually
understanding it once you have that
depending on what the objective is
you'll determine which algorithm makes
the most sense so if you're just
starting out with unlabeled data and
trying to understand different types of
groups that your data falls into you
might want to do something like
clustering which is a well-known
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
if you already have data that has
existed and you're trying to predict
trends uh or categories you might do
something like classification maybe with
a random forest or something like that
and uh use you know a part of your your
training training data for that to build
the model and of course you always want
to test it and then you want to validate
it with real world data and then the
last piece of it is interpreting the
results um so you might take a look at
the data and you might say okay based on
the set of recommendations that this
algorithm is giving me i want to create
three different targeted marketing
campaigns uh going on at different time
frames or if i'm a financial institution
maybe i want to understand who is the
best type of person to loan to and to to
underwrite um and then how do i identify
those people
so a lot of times that's the
typical framework and
there's a lot of back and forth so it
sounds linear to right now but during
the actual process you should be
prepared to go back and try different
algorithms a lot of times people like to
build several different models to
determine which one presents the most
accuracy
you'll also want to take into account
what does accuracy mean to you so just
to give you an example
if you're building an algorithm for the
air force to determine how often planes
need to come in for maintenance you
really want to err on the side of
caution for that right if you wait too
long and planes start falling out of the
sky it's going to be a really big
problem so your accuracy level uh you
might need to adjust your parameters to
be as conservative as possible so a lot
of that also depends on inputs that you
can give your data science team um to
make sure that you're prioritizing the
appropriate business cases
as you say that i hear a plane really
loud going over my house right now
um
going back to the the training piece do
you know if students continue to use the
skills specifically coding skills after
training has ended
do you have any tips to keep students
engaged
that's a good question and that's one
that we're working on internally right
now because one of the big trends that
we're seeing
is not just teaching individuals but
then also building this data culture um
and culture of data literacy
to foster innovation and collaboration
we have seen
incidences of people using our skills
afterwards i'll be honest with you it's
an area that we are um
looking to grow internally so maybe
deliver some assessments and surveys six
months to a year out from a particular
training program to see how they're
using those skills uh we're in the
process of doing that now with one or
two of our clients
we have seen
evidence of it so for example with the
programs that we run at hhs the
department of health and human services
what we've seen is that groups from the
cohorts that we've run continue to meet
on a monthly basis even after a program
is over so what does that lead to it
leads to an exchange of ideas problem
solving together and just again helps
build that collaboration that ripples
out and has a much bigger impact
otherwise we've seen other
folks who have taken the skills
that they've learned in our programs and
then applied that to
some proofs of concepts that have won
awards for their organizations uh want
projects and things like that so we do
see evidence of it um but as a data
driven person it's probably not up to
the standard that i'd like that to be
and again that's something that we're
working on with our company
rick i see you had a question about how
murav has scaled up the business
context
hi um really nice talk really
interesting topic i'm really happy i
joined today because
it's something that i was always kind of
interested in because i do a lot of
training with a lot of academic
groups and also for younger researchers
and people coming into the field
and i've done some work with companies
and i'm always interested to hear
how other people scaled up their
business and always interested to know
like if they bootstrapped if they got
investors how they standardized
procedures um how they kind of um met
standards for instructional design and
things like that so when you when you
introduced a topic and talked about you
have all these internal people and
instructional designers and data
scientists i was like wow like
how did you how did you got to that
level and how did you grow from your
background and
build up to this level
great question
um
it was a messy process i'll just just
put it that way um
you know for us we bootstrapped so we
didn't raise any capital uh we decided
that we wanted to retain control of our
company and where it would go for us it
was really important to do that so
because of that we needed to ensure that
we could keep the lights on
from day one
um we started out
relying on
individuals like data scientists to
build the content for us
because i actually didn't have a
background in data science obviously i
was coming in from education so i was
relying on the expert to build it up for
me and what we found is that there was a
really big
variety of quality in that content and
that just because somebody knows a topic
it's one thing to know it and it's
obviously a very different thing to
teach it and to understand where a
student is coming from
so even though it's much easier frankly
to rely on one person to build content
and deliver it and that's how a lot of
companies do it today we decided that
that wasn't the direction that we wanted
to go in because quality uh is really
important and
you know my background in education
makes it you know the number one
priority we want to deliver something
good so we developed a process in-house
that goes through several iterations
between our data scientists and our
instructional designers so that we get
the best of breed from a technical
standpoint and then also best of breed
from an instructional design standpoint
and it took us a few years to get to
that point um
you know now that we have a lot of
content it's a usually a faster process
but because we customize to almost all
of our clients so we incorporate their
data their use cases we still go through
that process not to mention the fact
that as we all know technology is a
double-edged sword it's great but it
updates every three months so we just
need to make sure that nothing is
deprecated uh that when we're teaching
it so we've developed this process and
actually one thing that we've worked on
internally which i'm really excited
about when we're talking about scaling
is that our data science team actually
developed uh an internal software that
will automatically customize content
for us so instead of us having to run
through that customization we can
actually take a data set input it into
the software with the shell of our
course and what it will do is actually
run that dataset and populate it and not
only populate it with the algorithms and
the data um
that we're running but it will also pull
relevant case studies from google using
key search words so we built a custom
search algorithm for that as well so
it's one of the beauties of running a
tech company is we get a lot of folks
who are very innovative very motivated
and
that will help us really um
fast track our scalability because now
the amount of time that it will take to
build this type of customized content
which is a central point of our value
will be much more condensed so i'm
really excited about that development
and we're beta testing it now we're
slated to
start using it more thoroughly
later this year and into next year
that sounds awesome yeah
the the underlying thing here by the way
is also just hire really good people and
trust them to do the right thing um
that's just the number one if you know i
we have an absolutely amazing team and a
lot of the innovations that have come
from our company come from them and my
job is to make sure that we have you
know enough business coming in and that
we create a really good work environment
for people so that we have a you know a
good good culture and good retention
rate
definitely
olivia i see you asked a really good
question around change management can i
pass the mic over to you for that
i can also read hey sure yes
can you hear me okay great um so i was
wondering if you cover any change
management topics more broadly with your
clients to help them
implement the new skill sets that their
teams are learning on a more
organizational level because i know that
that can be
a challenge like learning the skill set
is one thing having the whole
organization
adopt that sort of shift in um and using
that is a different story so curious how
you implement that or if you even touch
on it yeah absolutely would be a great
question uh we do touch on that because
we saw exactly what you were talking
about where
the joke that i like to make is if a
data scientist has an insight but nobody
around her understands it doesn't matter
right so no is the answer to that
question uh it's a lame joke but
sometimes people laugh at it uh and it
speaks to an underlying current of truth
where at the end of the day if your
executives and your leadership are not
on board with what you're doing it's
very difficult to implement the type of
change that you need in order to see
um
that massive return on investment of
your data so we do a lot of work with
executives we deliver a lot of workshops
with them as well as with managers
managers tend to be a little bit more
hesitant because
a lot of times
people in higher levels feel as though
they're being told that what they've
been doing is wrong uh and
our first point is to make sure to let
them know that that's absolutely not the
case obviously they've been successful
to get to this point and what we're here
to do is give them a whole other skill
set um and
you know a satchel of tools that they'll
be able to pull out and use to just
increase the the impact that they have
so we do a lot of work with change
management and get the leadership on
board so that they can actually start to
develop a data strategy around an
organization
thank
you uh mubanga i see you also asked a
question earlier around unsupervised
learning and supervised learning
could you want to add some extra context
there
uh thank you rachel yes uh i would like
to add a bit of context
to the question
i was actually i'm actually busy with a
master's degree in big data analytics
and
the modules only covered supervised and
unsupervised learning and it was the
usual cases where you look at a credit
card fraud
where you apply a logitech question or
svm
and some other cases where you apply
unsupervised learning for
clustering
or
principal component analysis
but what really
intrigued me was uh the realm of
reinforcement learning and how we can
use it to understand
or develop
new um
things like robotics or
landing the
lunar rover so i just wanted to
understand like in the mainstream
day-to-day job
are there any specific uh projects that
are reinforcement learning driven
because the research i'm doing right now
is try to bring
that aspect of machine learning into a
day-to-day job like an optimization of
the radio environment like how you can
make that um
don't democratize it basically but i
just want to understand like in day to
day is
most of the problems are simply solved
using supervised and unsupervised and
medicine is supervised or or do we have
that niche where we have reinforcement
learning as well
that's a great question uh so what i
would say is the majority of cases that
we see
and that we teach are
foundational unsupervised and supervised
machine learning um
so typically we'll look at clustering uh
we'll do some classification techniques
text mining is usually where people top
out
and text finding is actually one of our
areas of expertise and it's incredibly
it's it's grown in popularity a lot
especially over the past few years
because of the explosion of text data
that comes through social media as well
as customer comments
reinforcement learning is really
interesting that you mentioned that
because we actually were on a call this
morning with one of our clients who was
asking for a specific case for
reinforcement learning
um so we'll be building out
that program for for them
it's less common because it is a lot
more complex
so
we haven't seen a lot of demand for it
to date and i would argue based on what
i've seen a lot of the challenges that
people face today it's less about
building those types of predictive
algorithms and more about even
understanding the data that they have
currently to make better decisions it's
getting from that zero to one that we've
seen is most difficult and most in
demand and then beyond that
usually you have people who are
experienced enough who can develop those
algorithms without as much support
so that's a really good question we are
seeing requests for reinforcement
learning come up a little bit more now
into the mainstream but it's not quite
as popular as our intro to programming
uh
courses
thank you mero
arafat they see that you've asked a
question as well just in the chat now um
would you want to ask that one like oh
sorry there's a star there
um the question is did you have to help
any stakeholder overcome fear of ai even
for simple models for example
logic i might be getting that wrong
and if so how did you approach them
yes is the short answer to your question
a lot of what we do today is help
alleviate trepidation about using data
because
especially now organizations that are
not data driven feel like they're so
behind there's no way to catch up
whereas in fact i would still argue most
organizations are still at that
beginning stage
you know the key thing is to
just have a level of reassurance as well
as
appropriate terminologies to deal with
the fears that people have
so coming in and starting with hey what
level are you at and then letting them
know you know if you're talking to your
team about this as well you can just say
hey
actually
this is true across our industry right
most of our organizations uh in this
industry do not actually have this in
place so helping provide some of that
level that this problem is not unique
we've seen it before and there is a
pathway forward is really critical to
help people feel more at ease with the
idea of learning data
the other piece of the puzzle is just
giving them some
um
a basic framework of what data science
is and the way that i like to describe
it is that you are quantifying the
relationships around you that's what
data science is and we're able to do
that now on a much higher level because
we have this massive influx of data that
we've never been able to collect before
so
you know we
we look at data science as the
intersection between three things math
uh programming as well as industry
knowledge and the most important piece
is industry knowledge because at the end
of the day you're the ones that know
where the bodies are buried where the
biggest challenges are
and if we can build on top of that and
give you a little bit of that
programming skill a little bit of that
math background you can actually
leverage that much greater than somebody
who's unfamiliar with your industry
coming in
with data science skills um so we like
to set that tone i have
uh you know i have a one hour
presentation i do for lunch and learns
um
it's free i just like doing this
information that goes over the basic uh
and foundational terminology of data
science we talk about what is data
science big data supervised and
unsupervised machine learning and just
by giving them that baseline of
information they're already starting to
feel more comfortable because it's
really intimidating as somebody who
learned data science when i started this
company it is very intimidating and so
it's really important to just understand
that it's not magic it's a step-by-step
process and
by learning the terminology and the
foundations people actually start to
feel more comfortable with that idea so
then we just roll the ball forward from
there
definitely thank you it's actually just
making me think of a saturday night live
skit i was just
watching about like explaining what an
algorithm is to people uh now i need to
see that is that was that recent one
i think it was yeah okay oh that's what
i'm gonna be googling after this meeting
then
there's a question on how are the
resources for a project chosen
is the decision taken upon years of
experience
resources can you read the question one
more time um so it it's how are the
resources for a project chosen
and i think the question is maybe like
is it based on years of experience or
like certain industry experience or what
goes into that
that's a good question
there are two different factors so
there's resources in terms of
people and then there's resources in
terms of technology
i would say people trumps technology
every time because
most tools that you see in today's
environment essentially solve the same
thing like if you take a look a classic
example would be power bi versus tableau
they both build interactive dashboards
they both connect with a variety of
microsoft tools like excel and things
like that um power bi is way cheaper but
typically more people have tableau if
you're a tableau shop
you know i wouldn't recommend a solution
problem buying tableau uh buying power
bi licenses right use use the technology
that you have it's much more important
to have
people that understand the
project
um
you know i think somebody with industry
experience is a good person to leave and
then having a few folks that can
wrangle data build build dashboards
create that foundation with one or two
data scientists again it really depends
on the project um
the length of it the amount of data that
it has you want to take a look and map
out the requirements first is what i
would say so how much data do you have
um
think about how much time it will take
and double it and that's usually closer
to the actual estimate of the amount of
time that it takes
make sure that you understand what
resources are available to you so what i
like to do and what we do in some of our
executive level workshops is actually
help people brainstorm what tools do you
have in your organization today
and
there's a lot of different answers even
within one organization because
everybody buys these one off licenses so
it's important to get a good
understanding of the tools that you have
and
based on that roadmap you know that's
where you would kick it off and
doing things in like an agile method if
you're doing it in two-week sprints
helps you take into account if you
adequately prepare the resources or if
you need more
the one thing that i like to say about
any project any program is that
everything is iterative right at the end
of the day the thesis you might have to
start out with a project might not be
the the one that you end up with so
it's really important to stay flexible
and to make sure that you're evaluating
your progress and determining hey is
this actually going down the path that
we needed to or did we discover
something new that we now need to take
into account and go back a few steps and
retry some things so as long as we have
that level of flexibility everything
else falls into place
thank you and i i think i maybe heard
this on like a prior podcast that you're
maybe on but around the bi tool
conversation that it's not an either or
situation but more of a combination
and curious how you would advise us to
have those conversations internally
step one is asking what tools you have
because more likely than not what we've
seen is
organizations have a lot of tools that
they just never use
i've literally seen millions of dollars
wasted on
licenses that five people in an
organization use
so if you're looking at a way to cut
budget um take a look at that first and
then
you know based on that if you have tools
that are working well for the
organization keep them you know
i think most of the
if you look at the data analytics tools
that you see today um
most of them do the same thing
if we're being honest here and that's
why i love r and python because they're
open source tools that you know
you can use to build a lot of the same
stuff the interface is a little bit
different but with r i love using r for
prototyping it's very easy to do and
especially incorporating our shiny where
we can even build interactive dashboards
that are similar to tableau and power bi
without necessarily paying those
licenses so
you know it's
what i would say is it really depends on
the tools that you have and if
they cover most of what you want to do
just stick with them there's no need to
constantly go out and buy new tools and
that's also why our general staff
training and our executive level
trainings
we like to think that they're very
important because um when somebody sees
something new they want to get it
because i think it's a lot better but
giving them a base level of
understanding of how to approach data
and the questions that they need to ask
will help them be more discerning when
it comes to making these types of
purchases in the future
that's great feedback
um i know we're getting to the top of
the hour here so if some people have to
jump um and if it's okay to go over a
few minutes
i'm just wondering what's the best way
to get in contact with you if people had
follow-up questions is it linkedin
so linkedin is great um what i'll also
do is i'll give you my email um
send this to everyone
so
it's just my first name
we we decided my last name was too
difficult so uh just first name at
datasociety.com
if you have any additional questions um
feel free to reach out to me there i'm
usually pretty responsive although i
will be out of the office on monday and
tuesday vacation is important folks make
sure to take it uh but i will you know
happy to set up a time to chat further
if you have any other questions about
what i do what my company does
uh i also love
just helping people brainstorm about
these types of projects and objectives
for me
sharing knowledge is a core part of who
we are as a company so i'm happy to pass
along any information best practices
that we have about implementing the
types of programs that i've talked about
um or even the types of projects that
we've run
awesome thank you so much rob if it's
okay we do have a few more questions do
you have to jump to another
sure let me just i'm just looking at my
calendar here um
no worries if you have to i have a few
minutes i'll just email people it's it's
a mostly internal meeting i'll just
email them we'll let them know it's
running a few minutes late uh we can cut
that
recording if anybody asked me about it
later
sorry i don't want to we don't want to
steal you
yeah
this is fun for me so this is something
i could do all day although i know other
people have to run too
all right
thank you son let's go ahead i see
there's one other question that came in
from rfaf um did you ever find yourself
in a position where both causality and
predictive performance were asked for
but not having the scope to run any
causal experimentation if so how do you
deal with such requests
that just reminds me of one project we
did
earlier
a couple years ago with an association
um
that sent out a lot of marketing
campaigns was it like an association for
association so
um just you know tens of thousands of
emails every day sent and they wanted to
understand what uh the most important
factors were in terms of the open rate
so
they gave us a
very very large amount of data
we started going through it and what we
realized is um
almost all of their emails were sent on
tuesday mornings
so
how are we supposed to understand if
that's the best time to send it if we
don't have anything else to compare it
to
and that was a conversation we had to
have with our client and just say hey we
took a look at this data here's what's
going on and we can't make any other uh
you know predictions about that until
you start to collect more data so what
we recommend is start to send
newsletters at different times on
different days and then after a few
months we can come back and we can
actually evaluate which factors you're
most important so out of that story what
i would say is make sure if you are
collecting data or if you're trying to
do some a b testing actually do the b
and not just the a
because you need to have those types of
comparisons there to make sure that your
data is robust
robust enough to do that type of
analysis
um one other question was how do you
host your shiny apps
how do we host it i think we just do it
on
shinyapps.io if i remember correctly um
it's been a while since we've built them
sometimes we use an iframe and we post
it also internally on our website
depending on what the tool is
so we actually built a shiny app's
dashboard i don't know if it's still
running for the white house about five
years ago we participated in the
opportunity project uh which i'm not
sure if you're all aware of but it's a
great uh initiative that pairs
uh industry folks with agency people to
solve a particular challenge so at that
time we worked with the department of
education we built out a dashboard that
mapped resources school resources in the
city of philadelphia to help people
understand both
what resources were close to schools
they could also compare different
schools within a county
and um help determine you know if
there's no library within a mile of a
school is that a place to put a library
or a grocery store because food deserts
are also a really big issue so shiny
dashboards are great i think we hosted
it on shiny shinyapps.io if i remember
correctly
that's great and do they do they run
that every year
they do they do run it every year
okay yeah i'll have to check out that
link
um i just want to double check with
everyone are there certain questions
that i maybe have missed i'm trying to
do my best to scroll through but feel
free to
speak up live too
got a very short one
we talked a lot about explaining
algorithms to business users and
business users having an aversion to
using that output and
learning more about that
um
but it made me think it's very easy for
for me to say like oh yeah come on like
it's just multivariate regression like
you shouldn't be scared of it um i'm
trying to think on the flip side of that
are there people or groups that come to
me and say like hey this is the
direction we should go right you should
be on board
um and i'm like uh i don't feel great
about that so i i do first person there
but i'm curious um is there anything
that comes to your mind from that
perspective that you are averse to
um
that's a good question also a lot of
good questions today
i don't know if there's
so far we haven't been asked to do
anything that like i think is ethically
questionable i'll just put it that way
uh although i know that that happens a
lot and of course there's a lot of
discussion now with everything that's
happening at facebook
what i will say is i'll just add
entering to what you were saying which
is
i did put a lot of responsibility on
business people
what i didn't mention is that sometimes
it's really difficult for data
scientists to communicate
just effectively in general so the flip
side to that is making sure that your
data scientists can understand the
business enough to be able to connect
with other business users um
there is actually oh shoot i can't
remember the name of it there was a book
that was recommended to me recently um
that was
about communication
to
for
technical people to speak business
and i'm blanking on the name right now
but it has a big yellow cover on it and
i'll see if i can find it um
and so what i would recommend is on the
flip side as well just making sure that
your data scientists feel comfortable
speaking to some business use cases will
also help facilitate that i think it is
a two-way street although we usually
find one more than the other
thank you
my pleasure
thank you so much rob can i ask you one
last question absolutely
for people on the call who are hoping to
get into a data science leadership role
or maybe start their own company like
you
what advice would you give them
if you're going to start a company make
sure you're financially stable
and just let your friends and family
know you won't see them for a few years
that's my my first piece um it is very
time consuming it's incredibly rewarding
it takes a lot of time
uh you have to really love solving
challenges and figuring ways out in
situations especially if you're
bootstrapped like we are obviously if
you
uh are funded by investors there's a
different set of challenges there
if you're looking to become more in that
data data leadership role i would say
communication just as we've talked about
before is incredibly important so make
sure that you
feel comfortable communicating the
importance of data and that you can also
demonstrate that as well so in your
presentation start to bring in
data-driven results and research and
really define yourself as the data
person um
just put yourself in that role because
that's what we've seen
happen a lot with people who are you
know self-made data scientists and
things like that they just want to solve
a challenge they get more involved in it
and that's how they grow their skills so
i would recommend you know if you want
to spearhead those types and lunch and
learns
do it right um there's not a ton that's
stopping us from creating these types of
informal sessions
and and just keep at it it it's a lot of
work
um it's a lot of work but the end is
really rewarding when you get to see
um challenges like helping people
identify where the opioid crisis is is
most critical or where some of those
prescriptions are coming from so that we
can
help nip it in the bud um helping
predict outbreaks of covet in nursing
homes right all of these these critical
things that are impacting our day-to-day
lives um
you know getting goosebumps talking
about it now because this is really um
rewarding to see that type of an impact
that we can have and that all of you can
have too
yeah
thank you so much rob i i really
appreciate you jumping on and
chatting with all of us that was awesome
really appreciate your insights too
my pleasure really good questions i i
appreciate everybody being so
interactive um it makes my
my life a lot easier and more fun too to
do this type of thing so i'm really glad
you all were able to come today feel
free to connect with me on linkedin i'm
sure there's only one more obvious
lifter on there you can find me pretty
easily uh or feel free to send me any
additional notes emails if you want to
chat about anything just morave
datasociety.com and really best of luck
on your data journeys i hope this was
helpful and informative to you
thank you all for joining us well have a
great rest of the day and uh we'll put
the recording up on youtube too so i um
can put the link to data society there
as well
thank you so much morat have a great
rest of day
you